mon objectif principal c'est évidemment
de m'impliquer pour notre territoire à
25 ans geoffroy bex de keating c'est
déjà bien ce qu'il veut et surtout où il
va depuis juin dernier le jeune homme a
été choisi par les perrotin et les
perrotine pour être leur premier édile
il est surtout devenu le plus jeune
maire d'île de france
il a détrôné l'ancien élu paulette
deschamps qui était à la tête du
perray-en-yvelines depuis 20 ans
pour lui son jeune âge est un atout
quand vous êtes jeune vous avez envie de
vous engager vous avez envie de
participer à l'intérêt général et je
crois qu'on est une génération en quête
de sens qui cherchent à s'investir qui
cherchent à avoir de la responsabilité
sociétale
né à paris mais ayant vécu à rambouillet
toute son enfance c'est tout
naturellement qu'il s'est installé non
loin de là opéré en yvelines le jeune
élu a choisi de rejoindre le party les
républicains il y a trois ans donc c'est
quand même un engagement récent j'ai pas
j'ai pas commencé depuis tout petits à
m'engager politiquement donc ça m'est
pas venu tout de suite c'est cette
volonté de m'engager en politique c'est
justement dans ce moment-là début de
carrière où vous dites qu'elle est quel
engagement je veux mettre dans ma vie où
est-ce que où est ce que je veux
m'investir et c'est là que ça s'est un
peu déclaré pour moi est que que je me
suis investie début de carrière
politique donc mais également début de
carrière tout court
après un master management et
entrepreneuriat à angers il travaille
dans une start up spécialisée dans
l'intérim
mais sa carrière prend rapidement un
autre tournant grâce à son engagement
aux républicains il rencontre anne cabri
mère d'orson ville et présidente de l'
agence des espaces verts d'île de france
il devient son directeur de cabinet à un
moment il ya des gens qui vous font
confiance et qui se disent que vous en
avez la capacité et je crois qu'il faut
être en capacité de dire de faire
confiance à la jeunesse dans mon travail
à lagence des espaces verts de la région
ile de france
c'est surtout de l'accompagnement
stratégique à la prise de décision sur
globalement la protection de
l'environnement à l'échelle régionale
donc voilà un peu mon quotidien mayr
vice présidents d'agglomérations et
directeur de cabinet désormais à temps
partiel geoffroy backs de keating a déjà
beaucoup de cordes à son arc
le jeune élu a donc six ans pour faire
ses preuves